hi time for rock and roll trivia game
with Hank the angry dwarf and Gary
Dell'Abate Baba Booey
here's the deal Hank was on the show the
other day in his drunken stupor proved
to us that he knows a lot of rock and
roll trivia Dave Grohl's from what group
Dave Grohl IDs in nirvana Wow okay what
group did Jimmy Page played with before
Led Zeppelin The Yardbirds what's Axl
Rose's real name you don't know that
though barely know they told me he was
good let him take on Gary Gary weeks ago
yeah he thinks he knows everything what
I'll do is a hank will start the round I
will ask Hank a question if he gets it
wrong Gary gets the question right all
right you get a point for every right
answer a negative one point for every
wrong answer how many questions are we
gonna do I don't know all right here we
go thank you
first Van Morrison's first band was
called what them that is correct
all right yeah Gary doesn't get to
answer that one that was amazing in
itself that's a made you know that I
knew that I'm thinking there's one for
me because I'm sure he doesn't know that
okay
Gary Dell'Abate no Hank don't answer
Gary's or else you'll help them wait
till I call your name hello Keith moons
replacement drummer in the who is named
what Kenny Jones
that's correct one point for you yes
okay Hank I got it
what band was Peter Frampton in before
he went solo humble plug right that's
right so you gotta beat me because
sooner or later I'm not gonna know when
he's gonna answer he hits that baby
bottle filled with vodka
you know Gary's only hope is that Hank
keeps getting drunk yeah I hope that I'm
gonna win he's as drunk as he's ever
been here all right Gary Dell'Abate what
was the whose original name Gary
who
the high numbers correct oh did you know
that Hank yeah okay Hank
who played keyboards on let it be Billy
Preston correct Gary Dell'Abate what
lead singer was both in the Moody Blues
and wings lead singer in the Moody Blues
don't say anything any miles but I know
it
Gary Dell'Abate is up give me a second I
got the guys name that's the Irish guy
hey hey hey burr I don't know I don't
know it all right Gary negative one Hank
Jenny Lane right he's Rain Man of
students Rain Man the guy's loaded the
now you get the question what rock and
roll band is mentioned in the song smoke
on the water Frank Zappa and the mothers
of invention that is correct
hey come on Gary Dell'Abate who had a
hit with the song cars Gary Numan that
is correct
did you know that yes he does more than
you so far he's winning all right are
you ready Hank yes okay which 60s
girlfriend of Mick Jagger recorded their
song as tears go by Marianne Faithfull
that is correct
Gary go home I knew that one I can't win
now cuz he's not gonna miss any ready
not my fault all right this is uh this
is Gary Dell'Abate all right all right
this lefty is the lead guitarist for the
cars Elliot Easton that is correct
say I didn't that would I didn't know
damn
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you ready yes okay according to
Pearl Jam his daddy didn't give him
affection Jeremy that's correct I think
he would know that I Jesus I didn't
think he would be current he is current
all right I'm gonna give you an album
title Gary you give me the band okay
damn the torpedoes Tom Petty and the
Heartbreakers that is correct
Hank music from the big pink the bent
right I was ready to jump on Jerry
it is really gears cream that's right
Hank Hank oh that one yes
are you ready Zen yatta man Dada sleep
Matt no wrong Gary the police that is
correct
okay now it's my turn
your attorney now it's your turn all
right Gary
all right all right tell me who's sang
these songs green-eyed lady Gary named
the group don't think we didn't ask you
the same do you know the lyrics
Oh Gary yeah Hank green-eyed lady this
sport is your sport Hank drinking and
trivia so what's the score now it's now
8:00 to 5:00 and it's and it's our
history and it's his turn
ready I'm gonna name a song Hank tell me
who sang it you ready yeah okay it's
cool this is gonna make right this is
going to you okay all right
eyes without a face Billy Idol right
Gary Dell'Abate eye of the tiger
survivor correction he's right who sang
this song Hank can't you see I don't
deal was that one with the Marshall
Tucker babe Marshall Tucker Band it's
Gary's turn all right Gary named the
drummer in this band the cars yeah the
drummer of the car that's right not a
clue
okay that's minus one all right that's a
minus point for you too who is it David
Robinson Gary who's saying draw the line
guess up because uh all the brothers
wrong the Allman Brothers is incorrect
Hank
Aerosmith's correct I almost met
he's falling off the chair Hank's
falling off his chair it's my ass and I
gotta pick him up
Hank is in the lead 8:00 to 5:00 and
it's Hanks turn I'm gonna give the
nickname of some rock stars tell me who
the rock star is all right Hank the
Lizard King Jim Morrison correct Gary
Dell'Abate the Motor City Madman the
Motor City Madman Ted Nugent correct
Hank the Thin White Duke
David Bowie that's right Gary Dell'Abate
Pigpen Pigpen do I have to know his real
name
the real name take pen the guy from the
Grateful Dead the keyboard player but
Pigpen Markham I don't know Hank what is
it I'm gonna stop the contest Lois Gary
you gotta be blown out by things now
absolutely he knows he knows every mean
you know a lot of stuff but Hank just
knows every day no oh I knew the other
day he started answering stuff that it's
really weird I knew I was doomed to lose
Hank congratulations on beating Gary
like that